peace be with you salaam alaikum take
you for tuning in to the D show we're
here at the mass it now I got a special
guest when I come back here to Tyrese
Gibson right well Tyrese Gibson came
across a video and he texted it and he
was fascinated by it now the person who
made this video that Tyrese Gibson after
his good friend Paul Walker died he's
here with us here on the Dean show
that's right when we come back don't go
anywhere this exciting episode we're
going to be talking about this video
that really fascinated Tyrese Gibson and
what was the message in it here when we
come back on the D show
this is the this is the pain you know
this is the days of the theme is the
mean you know this is the salmiakki show
you ok Sarah come on Sally hey how you
doing all very good to be here auto
brothers in Australia very good popular
they send you this allah salaam alaikum
tonight to check out late go to
everybody australia got a really great
community there hamdullah you doing some
wonderful work stuff below critter hell
of reward you to create a reward you you
got a text message somebody texted this
video you did it was called what was it
called meaning of what the meaning of
license people are seeing you know some
some of the video here these guys are
like God hidden no guitar and and other
guys like that on some the drums it was
what's this all about basically it's a
video to make it this thing make people
thought ponder over over there meaning
of life you know many people are lost in
this delusion of this world whether it's
the past cars the woman the drugs the
alcohol the music the movies the
entertainment we're all just in this
illusion of this world so it's gets made
to make people get out of this illusion
and start thinking about what is your
meaning in life so that's the basics of
this video now what happened with tyrese
gibson you know his friend and asked the
ultimate reality def yes and you know
people again with the whole you only
live once part walker famous fast and
furious you know at the prime of his
life yes he got in a car accident and
then Tyrese Gibson I guess now that's
his best friend sad incident happens but
he came across your video were you
shocked surprised
at first I was shocked but then I was
happy you know because it's tragic it's
not just Tyrese Gibson it's absolutely
everyone that's alive whenever death
comes upon anyone it makes them start to
think and ponder over there over there
purpose in life as a losses in the Quran
and how political actors or tomorrow
father that verily this world yo-yo
rivalry rivalry in this world eludes you
until you visit the graves until death
overcomes you then it makes you think
what am I doing here where am I going
and you start to think about your
purpose in life so it's a sad reality
that affects every single one of us
until death hits us we start to think
about these things and it's and it's
good that this is the way I love rings
expecting it that's very um you know
true many people they don't reflect
about this ultimate reality you know
just chasing the material hello everyone
14 13 and Tyrese Gibson I was uh we sent
out a special shout-out to him you know
trying to give him you know some some
advice also a lot of these celebrities
when a tragedy happens and it happened
to you know someone who was taken away
that was close to him he said that look
this what was the exact tweet now that
he said about your video think I'm not
sure I think said this gave me what this
gave me like it understanding your
purpose with everyone we did well this
is a message from Allah you know it's
not for me i'm nothing special but when
you talk about what allah has sent that
hits the hearts that that is what
penetrates the house that's the
interesting thing at that moment of
vulnerability a person sees that you
know what i'm going to be in the grave
tomorrow also doesn't matter how much
money you have and they see the like he
did what that message in the video it
just makes sense you know islam makes
sense it's not it's not a progression
it's very rational irrational you don't
need to take a leap of faith to believe
that a creator is in control of this
universe you need to take a leap of
faith to believe that everything came
from nothing that requires a leap of
faith but to believe that you know a
creator creator dude in an impeccable
form it's amazing eyes that are better
than any camera you can ever get like I
mean I'm into my videography and I can
get to you this that nothing compares to
the human eye so it's rational to
believe that it's an intelligent design
this is a rational belief so we've got
to get people to start thinking with
them right but now what do you have to
say some people you know they're drawn
to Islam they have an affinity to Islam
because it just goes with the innate
nature but now you know what when they
start to share maybe with their friends
is not the most in thing the most
popular thing we're gonna say about that
unfortunately the shape on it does a
beautiful job of distracting us and
beautifying everything around us you
know it's even the most lowly of things
you'll make it look so beautiful I don't
know how the show youth on does it but
he will distract you with the most you
know fragile of things to keep you away
from pondering over your purpose in life
so we've got to start penetrating the
heart i'm going to start penetrating the
mind bringing people out of this
delusion of this world to start thinking
about their purpose we're going to talk
about some more of this when we come
back here in addi show don't go anywhere
what are we doing here and where are we
gonna go it's like we just woke up one
morning and then it's welcome to the
show don't ask any questions just go
with the flow make as much money as you
can and try your best not to get rope
copy everything you see on the TV from
the hairstyles to the clothes and don't
think too often just do exactly as
you're told and if you ever get confused
and just turned towards the alcohol you
still hear thoughts then just turn up
the radio as you learn to live a
lifestyle of drugs sex and rock and roll
but in all honesty I just need to know
is there more to the cycle then growing
and getting old living and dying just to
leave behind a happy home and a whole
lot of property that somebody else is
going to own I just really need to know
before the caskets closed cuz I'm not
willing to gamble with my soul nor am I
ready to take any chances these are just
simple life questions and I'm just
searching for some answers like what are
we doing here and what is our purpose
how did we get here and who made us so
perfect and what happens once we go or
is this world or really worth it please
subscribe to the dvo follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below please also help support
the V show by making a donation in the
link below back here on the D show
Tyrese Gibson look look if you're tuning
in we got the brother who made the video
that penetrated the heart of Tyrese
gifts and so many millions of people out
there I mean they got to benefit from
that now the thing is that again going
back to the you know we're not trying to
many people are trying to win a
popularity contest with their friends
you know
with you know competing with the
different actors and celebrities that
are out there trying to win this Emmy
and that Emmy but now many people forget
about impressing the one who created us
right so now let's say a person again
Tyrese Gibson specifically let's say he
saw this is made by Muslim the message
is clear but again now maybe he goes to
you know Reverend run you know Reverend
run his friend or some others and they
start sharing this and they start saying
you know Muslims are terrorists you know
I mean they start to it's not the cool
thing you might lose some some of those
friends right what do you say how do you
look past that get past that the shrink
to accept his truth first of all most I
like to thank Tyrese Gibson because he's
done a big job in dispelling many
misconceptions that are out there so I
really thank him for that and we
acknowledge that he's done very well
actually I think very good that we can
benefit from however you're right you
sometimes Dawa isn't the cursing in
something since as it is called to be
the Muslim kid you know amongst Muslims
at conventions like this it's cool to be
a day but there are times people found a
shoe oh you know with all the
misconceptions about terrorism
misconceptions about you know we don't
even need to go there but it's not the
cool thing to do so you have to
sacrifice yeah from your reputation to
give the doubt and as we know muhammad
saw said i'm the greatest of all
creation he was ridiculed he was abused
he was called the worst of names even
though he was the best of mentor best of
creation to have walked this earth so if
he went through it why shouldn't we yeah
the brothers now people are seeing these
two brothers now they're also I believe
they were what were they dancers like in
the class yes then my two friends are
your two friends irrespective they were
out there you know promoting us from
promoting the nightclubs look the
brothers like you know these two stars
man they were out there getting women
hanging out doing everything that you
know people want to do but now they're
on the Dean what tell us a little about
these brothers to be honest with you
I myself I used to before I got into the
Islamic spoken word I used to be mellow
forgive us but I say it for the benefit
of the viewers I used to fall into the
trap of you know the jazz music the rap
music and all this and the funniest
story is aiming the brother from the
video the first time I ever met him I
was trying to buy concert tickets off of
him for a concert which hamdullah never
actually went into happening and that
was the first time I ever met him and
then I add him on facebook and I just
see all these features at clubs and nice
in there and it wasn't the bestest
things to look at and I slowly became
religious just before he became
religious and the next time I met him it
was at medinah in in the proffered city
so to see that how far he had changed
like so far we both changed roughly
around the same time it was so inspiring
because I used to look at his features
on facebook and I say this his brother
you know we ask Allah to guide you but
let's look like a taxi there's a panel
Allah guides whom He wills how he wheels
and his brother was in the clubs you
know promoting dancing everything
everything but subhana Allah guides you
in here wheels and it was the most
inspiring feeling to have seen him in
the Prophet city you're like almost
brought a tear to my eye so these
brothers now they had lived for
satisfying their cardinal desires and
for winning those popularity contests
for vetting out is that our Lord's
explains the dunya in the Quran yeah but
now they're living for a higher purpose
well they came to Islam to the
submission to the crater not the
Christian and Islam is not something
that you just blindly jump into Islam
actually provides the proof and evidence
and you actually made a video talking
about some of these evidences in the
crowd so for the spectacle there he's
like come on all religion is just you
know you got to just blindly believe
that's not the same thing with Islam is
it again we've death it was death that
work out brother Amon it was diff that
made him realize you know hold
you know life isn't just parties music
day in day out friday saturday sunday
night there's something more deeper to
life you know Allah didn't create this
in vain you know he didn't give us this
impeccable worry just for us something
so vain as partying every Saturday night
there's something deeper and when he
realized that he gave everything up and
i think one beautiful thing about this
story in particular is our whole our
prophet muhammad sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said cairo compania how europe
indeed the best of you in ignorance are
the best of you in it when you come to
the religion and it's funny because they
used to promote clubs and dances and
music festivals but now they're
promoting a slab literally they go out
promote them they go to music festivals
until people come to the mosque come to
the massage and that's just in for
inspiring thing just to sing something
what is it about Islam on the one end
you go to the parties you know you go
ahead and you do what people do you work
hard during the week you go out on the
weekend you kick it you get you you
experience some kind of enjoyment right
and why would someone want to give all
that up they gave all that up what is it
that you experience in Islam that makes
you give that up the enjoyment is not a
true enjoyment that you throughout the
club's the enjoyment is not a true
enjoyment that you feel while you're
listening to music it's a temporary
enjoyment as soon as you know those
notes stop being playing let's not stop
playing and those endorphins stop the
hormones stop and the chemical reactions
in your brain reacting from the music
stop it goes away it's empty empty empty
and only in the remembrance of allah do
the hearts truly fine dress and this is
a true true tranquility and rest that
isn't temporary
now can you can you buy some of that can
you buy that I mean you're paying to go
to the nightclub you're paying for the
six-pack you're paying you know for that
pain actually look this is it's for free
but it's the most valuable thing on the
face of this planet yeah that one of the
scholar says he says that if they if the
disbelievers knew what we the happiness
that were you feel they would want to
steal it from us with their source and
that's the happiness we feel its
tranquility and it's a real permanent
eternal track with its priceless
priceless but my brief that you want it
that's the thing do you want it if you
want it we're going to be talking about
how you can get it to here in a dish oh
don't worry where the ignorance of the
insect can be shown as an example of
humanity just as the insect is fooled by
the bright lights of a trap that would
eventually destroy it man is also fooled
by the bright lights of this world which
would also destroy him although many men
have been fooled in the past some have
managed to run away from the fire before
consume them my name's Amon 26 and a
couple years ago as a club promoter
dancer the big on social media just
everything that wasn't writing life I
was blinded by Shaitaan like the glitz
the glamour I think to myself being what
I was used to be a dancer jumping in the
middle of a circle and having all eyes
on you and making people clap and cheer
I thought that was glamour I thought
that was well what a rush my name is no
I used to know me as Noah aim is my best
friend inmates within since high school
I used to go out together do everything
together you know the promotion's the
festival's the whole lot you know at the
time when you're there you enjoying the
way the environment years girls coming
at you the lights the the music your
heart pounding and you know the
goosebumps and you know the really good
really good feeling that everyone wants
to search for and Shaitaan did you know
he beautified everything around me you
know from women to money to acquiring
more and made it look so so so good
that you wanted more and if you took a
bit you weren't satisfied you still
wanted more and always felt to myself I
can go out every night you know
Wednesday to Sunday night and just party
and hang out and meet people and
socialize and I'm not hurting anyone
when the actual sense I was hurting
myself please subscribe to the dvo
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below please
also help support the D show by making a
donation in the link below back here on
the D show we're at the mass ethnic
invention and we are talking about some
of the more serious things that people
should be contemplating thinking about
some people right now there might be a
brother/sister you know what getting
tempted because maybe that the
University and a friend's been inviting
them to the fraternity sorority party
right and they're thinking of going and
the person to brother said come on look
honey Yolo you only live once and you
know she's thinking about it she feels
restricted maybe look I've been I've
been so good let me just do it one time
right what would you say to a brother
sister who are thinking of you know
kicking it now I think the most
beautiful hadith is the hardest that was
in the video was speaking about before
what of solar cells and upstairs his
example is like the example of a man who
lights a fire and that fire attract so
many insects in a rush at the fire they
rush at the fire again of the fact that
that fire is going to burn them
just because they're amazed by the
brightness of that light coming from the
fire but little do they know that that
fire is going to burn them and it is the
same thing with it with us we see the
bright lights of the nightclubs we see
the bright lights of the music that
entertainment and all these festivals
but little do we know that if we
continue chasing after them it will only
destroy us if not in this life in the
next time and it's a scary thought but
well lie this is the reality that we
can't run away from you know this is at
our doorstep and we can't run away from
it so if we die in this state that's it
see we have one shot in our reality it's
a bitter pill to swallow but we should
tell us what what do you see one of the
top challenges facing some of the I mean
we are going through similar problems
and struggles to be in Canada being us
now Australia and I'm sure a lot of
youth you know they come to you and ask
seek your advice what are some of the
challenge one of the major challenges
you see that the new far facing and
young adults metal or wood brother
nominally con for his foot but today
because I think he hit the nail on the
head we have an inferiority complex we
feel inferior we see everyone else and
all the riches that they have we see the
cars that they drive we see the
beautiful makeup and hair that some
girls wear and we feel so inferior look
at their look what they have look what
she has look at his look at look at her
boyfriend look at his girlfriend and we
go I want that why can't i have that why
is everything Haram and we begin to feel
so inferior which in reality is false
well lucky we have something that
everyone would die for we have that
happiness in our heart everyone should
die for we have an eternal the paradise
that abode the eternal abode it's unseen
but it's a turn and this is the best of
resting places that we could ever wish
for and we have a lot has given it to us
so why do we feel inferior when everyone
else is enslaved to their desires to
their image as the ship was saying
enslaved to looking good and slave to
feed to having the best girlfriend to
driving the best car everyone's enslaved
to these desires when us we are only
enslaved to the one master who knows
what's best fast and who is true to his
promise and has promised us paradise so
as long as we follow as the puppy told
us to follow how could someone in short
know that Islam is indeed not a religion
organized by man or men but it's indeed
the way of life from the crater who
created man and women and everything in
this universe how can they be sure Islam
is the truth it's a person first
acknowledge your Creator
put brush aside everything else
acknowledge that Allah exists now
swallow swallow the arrogance swallow
the you know the pride that you have be
humble you came from a philosopher you
came from a drop of semen be humble
admit your reality you were created from
the most glorious of creators was a la
the one and only acknowledge that once
you acknowledge that he is your Creator
acknowledge that he did not create us in
vain this impeccable world we are living
in this this immaculate amazing grand
world we are living in was not created
in vain there must be a purpose to it
and we are too naive and too ignorant to
figure out that purpose for ourselves
only a lot our Creator can tell us why
we are here if you have an iPhone if you
have an iPad if you have any form of
these technologies the first thing you
go to if you've never seen it before you
go to the apple store why because Apple
made the phone that you are desperately
trying to figure out how to use likewise
you go to your Creator and he'll tell
you how to use this body how to conduct
your relations with everyone around you
and Allah has not left us alone Allah
has given us this manual on how to give
our lives from the profits from Adam
Abraham
oh Jesus Muhammad is the peace be upon
the lord with Muhammad peace be upon him
being a final seal of all of them and
this is the truth what do you say what'd
he call Australians Ozzy's Ozzy's here
okay so you know in that in that part of
the world there was someone who took
some people hostage and we just hate
when it's like oh man I hope it's not a
Muslim right we know what this Dean
teaches what islam teaches what it calls
to and doesn't call to that obviously so
what do you have with some people out
there now who are listening maybe Muslim
got his friend Tillis now sounds good
why all these Muslims involved you know
not every Muslim is a how does it go I
don't wanna take down oh god are you
gotta say look um al hamdulillah the
majority of Australians were mature
enough to realize that this man with
this this action of this man does not
represent our religion they will mature
enough to realize that they know is that
they have Muslim neighbors they've seen
the Muslim shifts on TV they know who we
are and they know very well that this
does not represent Islam to the point
that they made him a tweet a hashtag we
trend of Iowa overnight I'll ride
museums I'll ride with you to show that
look Muslims wearing this together we're
against this you're against this alright
with you too and I was the most
beautiful thing and was the most
beautiful message to show the world that
you know Muslims you know Islam does not
advocate these kinds of things and you
don't have to look far to realize you
know the Prophet peace be upon it a lot
of causing mercy to mankind who are we
to call him anything
last minute we have Tyrese you know he
was like man I want to meet this guy
made that video or anyone else who's out
there now they're tuning in what advice
would you give them think honda of your
purpose in life wallah but we are we
only here for 50 60 amp of the beast
upon him said the age of my own mar 16
is 67 years we're not here for a long
time we need to think about our purpose
in life we don't want help you know the
day we are resurrected to be the first
day we actually think about oh my god
you know why was I here this whole time
we need to think today procrastination
is only helping the site that shape on
Satan we're only helping the devil by
procrastinating any longer we need to
think about while we're here give us
some sort give us some thoughts and deep
deep thought struggle struggle and
strive like a lot of teachers us in the
Quran those who strive in the course of
a block he will guide them he will guide
them so strive and we asked for a lot to
guard our hearts towards because even
you know as Muslims we ask for guidance
we started with peace when with peace
thank you so much I guess there's my
pleasure to be here all right Zach Lohan
thank you for tuning in to the Dean show
so really reflect upon this beautiful
advice think ponder why are you here
just a party and play make a little
money a little dough and then you spend
it and then then what or you accumulate
a lot of money and then what you die and
leave it all behind no there's got to be
more to life but you have to be sincere
with yourself do you want to know Willie
why you've been created while you're
here what's the meaning of life
begin by asking the owner who created
your life who gave you this chance right
now that you have and are you going to
just waste it because deaf can approach
at any time so start to sincerely ask
the one who created you to guide you and
then take it from there simple as that
give you a little bit of homework and
then tune in here every week to the D
show subscribe if you haven't already
and tune in every week we'll see you
next time until then peace be with you
please subscribe to the dvo follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below please also help
support the D show by making a donation
in the link below